people used to be discovered on music on
mtv in 1987. today it's tick-tock
tomorrow it's going to be something else
and that's just always how it's going to
be it's just going to keep moving and
it's your job to move with it this is
not some nostradamus [ __ ]
this is just some humble hard-working
[ __ ] and i'll do that
to the great
we were talking earlier and you talked
about third grade
is when you started really realizing for
everybody here
so many people that i've met
today
really exude a lot of passion
you know they're passionate about the
space about their brand about their
process about their homies about the
macro the micro
for you how were you able to take such
an extreme passion and turn it into your
professional career what were the two
hurdles the one hurdle that actually
allowed you to do something i think all
of us want to do yeah great question um
i mean like you mentioned i've been
extremely passionate about music in
particular hip-hop and freestyling since
third grade since i was a little kid
um
and
it's something i was working on my whole
life i think the biggest hurdle for me
as i'm practicing and developing and
getting better and better and studying
and doing this with my close companies
the biggest hurdle for me was my own
sort of fear and insecurity and for me
that manifested in the form of
perfectionism you know in my mind for so
much of my life like into my 20s um
regardless of what my friend said oh
you're so [ __ ] dope off the top you
should go do this you should make this
what you do uh in my mind is that it's
not good enough yet you know it needs
more work it needs more development i
didn't feel like i was ready to show it
and uh turned out the biggest hurdle
you know on that note one of the things
that i really believe is that people and
there's a lot of people in this room
that are going to resonate with this
people that say gary you don't get it
i'm a perfectionist
the way my brain takes that is no you
don't get it you're scared
you're scared to put it out and you're
trying to make it look cute by saying
you're a perfectionist that's just
makeup for insecurity
and that's what you're basically saying
100 man that's what it was for me you
know because in my mind uh i'm a creator
you know it's never going to be good
enough for me
right like it's never going to reach
it's not going to actually be perfect
but the the biggest step forward that i
ever took creatively was to just show
people my [ __ ] what should i have for
you
um
you know i i've heard you know a lot of
your uh you know uh clips and content
that you've made which i'm a huge fan of
by the way it's so good for me to be up
here with you um you've talked to a lot
of young artists
about the power of tiptop yes and tick
tock has been huge for me too especially
in the last year um we've been really
really diving deep on tick tock we do
daily content on there um
what in your mind is like the next way
what's exciting to you in terms of what
independent artists and creators you
know like myself who don't have a label
and don't have a publisher or anything
like that what are you looking into
the next thing that you think is going
to be
i think for me my the reason my career
is what it is when it comes to this is
that i'm i'm always looking but i never
know
so many people think
and position me as like seeing around
corners or
i see the future i don't see any of that
i'm just a normal dude
what i do very well
though is when something pops off
i move quick
so four years ago when i'm talking about
tick tock
people's emotion about what they were
building on instagram is what stopped
them from seeing tick tock
people having 14 000 followers on
instagram and working hard for it is why
they didn't want to see tick tock
i have no feelings about yesterday
it doesn't matter what i accomplished an
hour ago everything is about tomorrow
and
that's why i've been able to see the
next thing
because i'm inherently
curious
i really don't get high
on my own supply
i don't think it matters that i've done
well for the last 20 years the next day
is predicated on how i do well the next
day
and i'm not scared to do the work
i wasn't devastated that i was big on
youtube and twitter and instagram when i
saw tick tock and had to start at zero
i'm like let's go to [ __ ] work
and so for me
people are way too emotional
about where they're found or where they
put in the work the world and technology
don't give a [ __ ] that you put in that
work there it's just going to keep
moving and it's your job to move with it
people used to be discovered on music on
mtv in 1987. today it's tick-tock
tomorrow it's going to be something else
and that's just always how it's going to
be and so for me
it's based on humility this is not some
nostradamus [ __ ]
this is just some humble hard-working
[ __ ] and i'll do that
to the grave you know it's funny when
biggie's album came out
i just remember when i
when it got to warning
and just i just
i grew up with hip-hop
and i i'm 46 so like beastie boys were
huge run dmc
krs one big daddy kane it was all really
cool
but big
big e's first album i was a freshman in
college
ru tang had dominated the last year and
had such a crazy sound
and there was so much talent
but i'll never forget when the song just
started with like who the [ __ ] is this
paging me at 5 46 in the morning and i
just remember
it was the first time i realized and i
think it's why i liked in hindsight i'm
like oh this is why i like krs-1
he paints a picture
but bicky when i was done with that
album i was confused i thought i was
biggie's friend
like it was so clear
he was capable of telling stories
in such a clear way
as if i was
like had a relationship with him on the
first listen
and to this day
i i
it really it really develops the way i
think about music yeah i've realized i
don't have i don't really think about
beats i know that people love it i
understand that people [ __ ] does get me
to move but for me
paint me a picture
take me into your world which is why
people's first albums really matter to
me because a lot you have your whole
life to write the first one
that first one changed my life so one
thing that that i have seen as a
challenge for my content um is
making shifts and transitioning like if
we're changing something up we decided
or what about
are the results not as good less likes
comments all of it
yeah so yeah oftentimes you know there
are certain things i do that are very
popular
and there are other things
that will sort
this is the subject matter that i think
affects so many people in here which is
people are scared to talk about
the [ __ ] they actually care about
they're scared to put out the content
that they actually want to put out
because they're addicted
to the metrics of social media
because somebody knows that they
normally get 500 likes or 50 likes
they're going to keep making the same
[ __ ] even if their brain and their soul
has evolved to a new place because they
don't have the humility
or the self-confidence
and
they're deploying insecurity
and it's a huge deal i see it with a lot
of people i see a lot of people that
came up the game because they were funny
but now they want to talk about some
serious [ __ ] and people want them to
just make them laugh i see a lot with
people that are models
attractive people that want to talk
about other [ __ ] but they know they get
more likes when they show their abs or
they show skin
and it's really unfortunate i think that
there's
a really important conversation to be
had
for people to make content they want to
make i grew up in the game of content
doing wine
and when i first started wanting to show
people who i really was which was i was
a wine businessman i just happened to
know about wine
people were [ __ ] pissed
the the content i put out today
started with almost every comment being
staying your lane wine boy
like stop what are you why are you
talking about business just tell me if
this red wine is good
and there was enormous amounts of push
back
my biggest thing overall for people that
follow me and have a sense is like
the thought of living your life based on
other people's opinions
is a guaranteed path to unhappiness
there is 0.0 people
thank you
there are 0.0 people that are happy
living based on other people's opinions
and we now live in a society
that has so much anxiety that people
spend most of their time looking to tear
down other people or gotcha or razz
and so you're in such a tough spot
so
for me
the answer to your question is
you have no option other than putting
out [ __ ] that you [ __ ] give a [ __ ]
about otherwise you're going down a path
that's not going to work you're going to
burn the [ __ ] out here we go so
the way your [ __ ] works is you take
words and you'll do it right yeah so i'm
gonna ask actually ask the crowd a
little bit how many words do you need uh
give me three to start three words
any three words wax w-a-s
flower moon bird
boomers moon bird
wax
and flowers flower you say moon birds
like a bird that goes to the moon like a
lunar verse okay hell yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
one more time for this man come on
appreciate it thank you how many hours
of practice to get to that moment
i wouldn't even venture to guess man
people say that thing about something
you know they're not going to about ten
thousand hours i probably practiced
freestyling for ten thousand hours in
college alone in the four years i was in
college
dating back to when i was 10 i have no i
have no idea so much [ __ ] time i mean
obsessive obsessive practice it's been
an obsessive love for me since i was a
kid there's nothing else i would rather
do with my time asking as my girlfriend
i'm freezing out around washing the
dishes of course i'm freestyling in the
car a freestyle while i'm walking around
the house i'm always freestyling and i'm
always trying to improve and get better
to me there's no [ __ ] limit
thank you man of course
[Music]
[Music]